[Musique]
le quidditch est un sport de balle issu
de la célèbre saga harry potter et se
pratique avec un balai on utilise nos
balais à nos biens bien moldus donc ça
reste des tubes en pvc quand on garde
entre novembre pour garder l'handicapant
fêtes du bas est sur le terrain
l'objectif est d'avoir plus de points
que l'adversaire en marquant un maximum
de buts en attrapant une balle magique
le vif d'or le gardien doit protéger les
trois anneaux et venir en renfort pour
soutenir et les poursuiveurs ce sport
regroupe plusieurs disciplines
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour en créer
un nouveau
et après on est sur des manipulations de
balles sur du dodge ball à on amer
américain on est sur la même
manipulation de ballon de volée sur deux
comment de la course au foulard
pour le disque d'or donc c'est plein de
plans de petits détails de sport
mélanger en en un seul créé il y a un an
et demi le club des aigles est cents à
participer à sa première compétition
officielle
samedi trois équipes se sont rencontrées
au championnat national de quidditch sur
le stade beltramini des clayes-sous-bois
cette année on a pu participer les
autres équipes ont été sympa de venir
nous voir
donc au clae de recevoir chez nous pour
la première fois est de permettre à
montrer aux clés que ben ouais on est
les seuls dans le 78 donc on a un
monopole est un privilège à avoir le
club comprend quatorze licenciés seniors
et une dizaine pour son équipe junior
c'est un sport mixte
c'est assez atypique et quand j'ai vu le
club au forum des associations
monsieur hewitt bas quitte à faire du
sport au moins c'est atypique ça me
plaît et j'aime ce côté à l'aide les
sound se fixe un prochain rendez-vous un
tournoi de quidditch pour la lutte
contre le cancer du sein